today we are gonna check out some hey oh
picking your nose too eh I've never been
here have you
have you seen any farm animals before
okay let's go explore together
me too like yesterday
oh very cool let's go
I didn't see anything moving no look at
this Bard Buddy's rescue at Las Vegas
Farm local honey fresh eggs
who is that
I gotta cut this is too funny I gotta
get it on my phone hold on wait wait
wait I gotta record this
I gotta record this I gotta record this
set to that okay what did you say that
is poo poo what did you say monkey tell
me again
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] bird
okay wait I was back here artisanal
bread Jelly Soap crafts rescued farm
animals this is so awesome what animal
do you think that is leg chicken leg
let's go check out your chicken legs
yeah
look at that over there what's that over
there the white thing it's a peacock
No don't touch them because they're
scared so you could look at them but
don't touch them
yeah it's a real one I think that's a
female don't get too close Okay because
you might make her nervous she might
think you're a bad guy because she
doesn't know you
you see she's the her walking away means
nah I'm scared of you
okay let's go inside
[Applause]
yeah let's go
we're entering the farm farmers market
and animals because the chicken legs
it says no children under 18 without a
mama or Papa
but you're with me so you can come
you're safe it says do not enter let's
go this way if you're by yourself
no exactly that's exactly what happens
before
how cool I know look at those chickens
over there do you see them over there
over there there's a cat there's a cat
there's a cat
yeah there's a lot of cats actually
yeah leave her alone though don't touch
them though okay they might not know you
so they might bite you just say hi look
they don't know you don't do that just
that makes them nervous you just look at
them and that's it
hahaha
can I take a picture with it look at
these are apples leave the cat alone
would you like to get some apples for
Grandma from a farm
yeah look at this kitty cat
oh they're so comfortable
do not touch them good job
there's one more there's four there's
one behind him
behind him look
oh my friends
[Applause]
okay leave her alone hey look at that oh
that one might bite you okay so just
leave him alone it's protecting her
friends
she might be hiding her eggs
so that one's telling you hey you better
be careful that's my friend I need to
know you tattoo
got a tattoo and we got some hay I'll
tell you when okay okay go
she likes it with her head her head
forward
and it's just stretching and now it's
just stretchy just ahead not the ears it
tickles her ears
that's it
let's cut him pet him I won't touch him
it's okay just pet him
now look at his eyes so cool
[Music]
I don't think they eat hay oh I need to
hey well you just take it off from my
wall yeah you want to give him some more
look at where is that they're all coming
they're all coming
oh
they're going that way oh look look at
their their head butting each other
they're playing look at them they're
playing
I think they're playing I think they
might be fighting what are they doing
over there
oh
what's going on what's going on
turtle food look at him no it's not
turtle food that's goat food look at
this look at this
one on the water
yeah they're cooling off
[Music]
peacock opened up its feathers yeah what
does it look like
nope it looks like a big fan
no do not touch it no we'll just touch
his wings No don't touch anything yep
that's what happens
be careful
do not touch him though okay
but don't touch them
what up chicks
what up ladies
relaxing yeah but not anymore that
you're yelling
she woke it up
look at these guys so cool
they're just minding their own business
eating their food you see them eating
their food yeah what do they eat
yeah seeds you see them look
yeah okay I'll follow you
what's in there dude and this one yeah I
don't see anything in here we're all in
there what's in here
there's water there's something here
[Applause]
okay I can't see it he's probably hiding
it's toad
I agree I think so too yeah let's go
check something else
there's horses and a cow dude I wish I
could ride a horse I wish I could ride a
horse you can they eat that hey yeah but
let's go look for another horse
the cows eat too come here look
look she's beautiful oh he's big he's a
big guy she's massive huh look at her
that got big
ger
he's relaxing you want to give her some
yeah well that's proof
that's a lot of poop okay let's see if
she wants this
let's look
oh she doesn't want it
oh hey girl
she doesn't want it yeah that's
different that was a different one
okay there's a duck look at the Ducks
hey look at this little horse
see a little horse
oh oh they're afraid of you
look at this guy
yeah here here give him some more give
him some hay
not the bag oh that's nothing give them
more give them more
no don't throw it don't throw it don't
throw it
do you want a pet a Ted
do you want to pet him
[Music]
okay well
[Applause]
they are cute babies
wait tiny little baby there are little
little chicks little ducklings
how cool
yeah
trash
it's gonna just grab it with its tongue
okay so don't be scared yeah they're
friends here a lot more a lot more a lot
look there's a big animal there you go
it's gonna grab it with your tongue so
don't be scared you see don't be scared
it's just his tongue there's no teeth
give him some more time they're growth
they are gross but who cares let me see
look look
you're gonna do this
here dude
you're a big guy
oh look at that yeah yeah that's good
thank you let it go
well he eat the whole thing yeah trash
right there
hi
good boy girl I don't know what you are
okay
I got some more want some more sure no
no that's Jet doesn't eat that one they
pooped in that one
yeah oh sorry the trash cans right here
my love hey dude you're beautiful
and your eye looks
dirty as hell
look at this guy
in the top yeah how does it feel
to talk I'm touching his back okay how
does it feel
careful okay
oh
he's Dusty huh
today yeah well look at that guy whoa
look at that guy that was crazy
he's so funny
whoa
that's hot
that guy's very mad right he's not mad
he was itchy his back was itchy so he's
scratching his back on the floor no but
he'll
okay what's his name I'll give him
I'll give him Jason
Jason why Jason because Jason because I
like his he looks like a Jason yeah okay
what's up Jason I'm sure you already
have a name but we'll call you Jason for
now
then tomorrow
and tomorrow we'll call him horsey okay
he's a horse cool it's gonna be so hard
for me to ever get over
how freaking cool
my car looks depending on like how the
Sun is setting I love this wrap so much
this dude
is exhausted
he's been sleeping since four o'clock we
got home and he was like let me turn
this down here
he was like
it's like Mom
can I put on my pages and go to bed
or take a nap and I'm like a nap Beauty
you want to take a nap
and then I turn into the candle guy from
Beauty and the Beast B my guest be my
guest yeah because
[ __ ] be crazy you know what I'm
saying yeah he's been sleeping for quite
a bit and normally I don't really try to
regulate because sleeping too much
because he actually doesn't like to
sleep he's an early bird he'll wake up
at four or five six it doesn't matter
how late he goes to bed
so anytime he does wants to go to sleep
I'm like please go to sleep
uninterrupted do you boo please go Eve
but
what's happening right now what's also
happening right now is
this looks like [ __ ]
but trust me it's gonna be bomb
because I didn't make it
Trader Joe's fire roasted bell peppers
and onions and then I'm gonna make
some turkey some 99 one
because it leaves a lot of room for play
time
after dinner which plate time to me
means dessert and dessert to me means
like a diet [ __ ] I don't know ice
cream or something since this nine week
not nine weeks all right 12 week get
lean program has started I've lost about
15 pounds already
can you tell
do I look jacked can I go on muscle
magazine already
no just kidding that's not the goal the
goal is really to just get lean feel
athletic work on my PR's all of that
it's coming to fruition I feel the best
I've ever felt I look the best I feel I
ever looked
um I'm the strongest I have ever been
and I do like to preface that with not
in terms of PR but in terms of
mindset my body's not injured I'm not
lifting as heavy as I used to like
technically heavy but or literally heavy
but technically my form is
oh it's so nice
but um yeah so that's what I'm doing it
for it's been a lot of fun not the
hiding part but just the whole big
picture part of it has been a ton of fun
I hope you turn out good because I never
know what the [ __ ] I'm doing here
just letting the little water evaporate
I added
some seasoning to it so I added this
you always have to add this
whoa I didn't screw that on I almost
screwed it up this and then
um I added some garlic and that is not
mine
even though I wish you were
and here is the final product
not bad oh I also did some mustard
because it's so lean of a ground turkey
that I wanted it to have some sort of
moisture so
that's what it got
the fun guys here the fungi
ate
I saw pictures of all those animals
[Music]
but I said don't touch the cat and what
did you do
yeah
they told him not to touch the cat but
he touched the cat
[Music]
they are mad
so now I'm attempting to make air fryer
fries french fries did you season them
already yeah
just salt and garlic powder do you want
something else
you have a Cajun
oh okay you'll do it after then
oh
um so I cut them up put them in some ice
water to get all the starchiness out uh
for like maybe 15-20 minutes pulled it
out Pat them dry this is what's gonna
get them crunching on the outside soft
on the inside
coated them with some avocado oil
some garlic powder and some sea salt
tossed it and now I have the first batch
going in here I'm going to let it cook
or air fry for six minutes
400 Degrees open it up toss it a little
bit just so it's evenly done total 18
minutes that means I'm gonna pull it
open toss them about three times
so wish me luck hopefully it's good
verdict how's my turkey
out of 10.
whoa okay what about the fries
I love it really yeah because they have
zero fat fries that's a huge deal to
even eat fries on a diet slightly
crunchy yeah I think I've
hear that I think I've I've I'm
perfecting it all right guys
today was a fun filled day
exposing tiger to all of these animals
and having them guess them absolutely
wrong he was looking at a turkey and he
was calling it something else and like
he didn't know what anything was called
we are straight up City people it is so
sad he tried kicking a turkey in the
chest
because the turkey was like right next
to him and the turkey and taika there
was only like a foot difference don't
kicked the turkey yeah and then it
started opening its beak yeah and I was
like uh Tech I think you want to move
away but I was on the phone talking to a
realtor yeah yeah
and then and then what'd you do
yeah
and I was like daika No And then it was
another one where there was a rooster
is it
what about the rooster he was following
a hen and then Taiko started following
the rooster and then the rooster puts
its wings out like that and then I'll
just kick him I'm like no dude they'll
Peck you and it hurts he goes I'll shoot
him with the gun I'm like where's your
gun dude
and then I was like nah he's like he's
like I could beat him up I'm like no you
can't roosters are wild
[Music]
I will be on that bushes and I'll jump
on him
but he could fly what if he flies away
now what you didn't think it through
dude you didn't think it through
yeah
so there was a lot of learning today and
it was a fun fun day we ended up buying
those feathers because there were so
many peacocks so they sell them at their
gift store
I bought or we bought
some fresh
from the garden or from the farm fruit
it's not beautiful like the way we stay
at the supermarket this is the real deal
this is what it's supposed to look like
so we picked some of that
got some veggies is a cucumber a veggie
or a vegetable I mean a veggie or a
fruit which one
uh that's my veggie my opinion but it
has seeds and I thought that's what
makes it a fruit
because avocado is a fruit did you know
that
so we got no veggies today I don't know
and then what is it called a freaking
goober oh what's that you're a goober
it's like when those things are like
like boards what are they called there's
another family of names of them okay you
just surpassed my intellect I always do
yeah whatever anyways
um and then I picked up some Jam that
they make
I hope you guys know that this one is
Green Goddess Plum and of course I tried
it diet or not plum jam
and fig I love me anything fig I'm a fig
[ __ ] look at this homemade they were
delicious taika picked up some peanut
butter cookie did I take a bite
absolutely I did and that one was really
good and then they had chocolate chip
which was taika's favorite
did I take a bite of that because that's
chocolate
absolutely I did but the peanut butter
one was actually way better they're
super soft super moist so I might go
back and I'm not gonna die anymore and
pick up more of these but yeah check
them out they're at a Farm Rescue
um organization and it seems like it's
all family brand
um so it was super cute to support
locally and to support animals and to
expose my son to things that are not in
the Concrete Jungle So yeah thank you
guys so much for watching and I will see
you tomorrow but for now let's watch
these teachers players are so cute
yeah What's this called
[Applause]
that doesn't sound Chinese
cheese
design these are [ __ ] easy